في كل المستشفيات التي نعمل فيها في قطاع
غزه وخاصه مستشفى الشفاء ومستشفى الاقصى
ومستشفى النصر جميعها راينا انها تحولت
الى مخيمات للنازحين والسبب هو ان الناس
ياتون الى المستشفيات لانهم يبحثون عن
الامان وعندما تستهدف تلك المستشفيات يجب
على هؤلاء الناس ان
يغادروا بالاضافه الى ما كان ينشده
الغزيون في التجاء الى المستشفيات
باعتبارها منشات يفترض انها تتمتع
بالحمايه حتى في الحروب وجدنا بالتحليل
الجغرافي انها تحتل نقاطا مركزيه هامه
واستراتيجيه في مختلف مناطق القطاع حيث
يقع مجمع الشفاء على مفترق طرق في حي
الرمال على مساحه تقدر ب 45 الف متر مربع
وهو الاكبر في غزه متوسطا لمنطقه حيويه
ذات كثافه سكانيه تقدر ب 750 ال نسمه
كما يعد موقعا لوجستيا يربط الميناء بمركز
المدينه وتم استخدام موقعه سابقا كثك
عسكريه منذ الانتداب البريطاني لاهميته
الاستراتيجيه يعني هذه المستشفيات هي داخل
مناطق سكنيه عندما تتحدث عن اكبر مجمعين
طبيين الشفاء وناصر الشفاء يعني بجانب
مخيم الشاطئ وناصر داخل مخيم خان
يونس
l